conference season has kicked off and the
Lib Dems are having their get-together
on the south of course to that end I'm
very pleased to see that we're joined
now by their hormones pork swing
Ed's Davy mr Davey are very good morning
to you good morning mr. Davy I wonder if
we can start with events of in and
around Parsons green I mean in your
capacity as Home Affairs spokesman just
how safe do you assess that we are in
the UK at the moment well it's clearly
very troubling we're thinking about all
those who've been directly affected
injured we're very proud of the way the
emergency services have tackled that but
we've got to remember that this year
we've had five terrorist attacks get
through our security shield that's the
largest number of attacks getting
through for many years so we need to
think deeply about how we can keep our
country safe and that's going to look at
everything from investing in our police
at all levels Community Police as well
as those directly attacking the anti
terrorists and and other issues and
Liberal Democrats here at Bournemouth
will be debating exactly what we should
do to defeat terrorism at one
particularly unhelpful intervention as
identified by yourself was that of the
President of the United States Donald
Trump you suggest that it was insulting
to the victims of the attack that he
shows that he is not fit for the office
of US president any response thus far
from the Oval Office
of course not he only deals with his own
ego and that's what's so shocking and
it's not just on the terrorists outrage
at Parsons green it's on issues like
peace in in Korea where I'm afraid that
the current incumbent of the Oval Office
present Trump is extremely irresponsible
and uses his tweets in a way which I
think undermines the the search for
peace and security
but if number-10 can't Corral the
president into an appropriate position
on days like this I mean what hope that
the Liberal Democrats calm Affairs
spokesman I suppose the broader point
here is as Liberal Democrats gather in
Bournemouth for their conference I mean
what is the point of your party these
days well I personally rather
or humble than you're suggesting I
wasn't thinking that mr. Trump would
change his mind I was expressing my
point of view and you'd expect that from
a Democrat politician but our party is
actually in much greater spirits than
you might expect we've had a bad two
general elections there's no doubt about
that and we need to be humble and clear
about what went wrong but we've had a
massive increase in membership more than
doubled and with lots of people joining
the Liberal Democrats from the other
political parties but also from people
who've not be involved in politics and
you have to ask yourself why they're
doing that I think they're doing that
partly because of brexit people have
very alarmed or what's happening to our
country turning our backs on the rest of
the world but also they're looking for a
party that's going to tell the real
truths about what's happening in our
world that hot to hold the powerful to
account whether it's in business and the
corporates whether there's government I
think they want a a party that wants to
take on the system and Liberal Democrats
have always been that when we've been at
our best but the single biggest issue
occupying British politics of the moment
is of course brexit and you do have a
somewhat distinctive position well you
did at least until the Labour Party
decided to move slightly towards the
soft brexit option I mean I suppose
given that you have this distinctive
position given the fact that you haven't
exactly seen any shift in the polls
you're still around about 7% where you
were back at the general election how
can you convince those centrist remain
of voters to come to the party you're
clearly not doing it thus far well
people are joining the party but you're
right in terms of the ballot box we're
not yet getting that support I think
people are waking up to the fact that
the Conservatives are completely divided
and unable to give a leader almost
unable to negotiate and they're not
dealing with the issues that people care
about outside brexit like the health
service like our police like our schools
and I think Jeremy Corbyn may well have
tweaked the Labour position but it's
increasingly clear that they are not the
opposition to brexit they support brexit
so we have to brexit supporting parties
in Parliament and the Liberal Democrats
and you're right we've got to persuade
more people I think we've got to reach
out to leave voters to explain why we
think the European Union helps us be
more secure and more prosperous and also
how we
can address those concerns that they
raised during the referendum and since
so I think for our possessed for a
moment mr. Daly can you consider the
words of your of your deputy leader Joe
Swenson you know we haven't been able to
make the connection yet and resonate
with a lot of those in the center that's
the task we need to get into with the
radical solutions the radical proposals
the policies from which Liberal Democrat
Conference used to be famous for that
they're simply not there anymore
well I I do agree with part of what
Joe's saying we do need to think fresh
and think bold and go back to some of
our radical roots and it's in there in
our policies I don't think we've been
getting it over so for example climate
change which I've been responsible for
both in government and outside I think
our message which is pretty radical is
about making sure this changed from the
fossil fuel economy we've had for
decades
happens more quickly and involved people
empowers people gives people lower
energy bills as well as green energy
bills that's a real taking on the status
quo and I also think we need to do that
in terms of inequality corporates and
large businesses aren't being held to
account properly Jeremy Corbyn in his
election managed to tune into that a
little bit but not in ways that would
really ensure that corporates treated
their workers their shareholders their
employees much better and Liberal
Democrats need to get onto that core
economic agenda and with Vince Cable I
think we've got the leader to do just
that well so you're essentially saying
that the message is right it's just a
problem with the messenger I'm sure of
Vince will be very pleased to hear that
well I've said both actually if you
listen to me I said we do need to ensure
that our message which is the radical
liberal message where we want to shake
up the system as well as making sure
investing the key things that people
want their schools and their hospitals
that message gets over louder and more
clearly and we've got to do that while
remaining very strong on the brexit
position and I think under Vince we have
someone who is seen as a future prime
minister if you put him up against
Theresa May or Jeremy Corbyn I think the
majority of people would rather have
Vince in number 10 because he comes with
huge credibility particularly on the
economy the only person in British
politics who call the financial crisis
before it happened
a cabinet minister port for industrial
strategy to ensure that we had for
example two million young people being
trained as apprenticeships that's a
record in government a record in the
economics profession that no other
leading politician has so I'm delighted
that he's leaving the party and I think
as the messenger he'll be one of the
most effective we've ever had but I
think he knows we need to sharpen up our
message and when we do I think you'll be
surprised just how well will do Davi
thank you very much for joining us hope
you enjoy conference it looks like you
certainly got the weather very much